que je réalise avec le genre d'homme en
avait un autre combat ma vie qui est
celui de la sécurité routière s'agit
d'un projet de loi qui vise à mettre en
place des tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 24 mai l'ordre
du jour du sommet européen qui a débuté
tout à l'heure chamboulée depuis
l'interception hier par la biélorussie
d'un avion de ligne transportant un
ancien collaborateur d'une chaîne
d'opposition minsk affirme avoir agi
dans son droit au camp une alerte à la
bombe au second juge cette action
raisonnable bruxelles dénonce un
comportement scandaleux et illégal
l'union européenne qui annonce une
réponse très forte ce soir l' agence
onusienne de l'aviation civile y tiendra
elle en une une réunion en urgence jeudi
le certificat numérique au vide européen
ou plus simplement le passé ni terre il
doit entrer en vigueur à partir du 1er
juillet pour faciliter les voyages au
sein de l'union européenne
clément bonne le secrétaire d'état en
charge des affaires européennes prévient
seuls les vaccins autorisés par le vieux
continent seront reconnu excluant de
facto les sérums russes et chinois à
l'avant est sympa sanitaire ou impasse
géopolitique ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face un véritable processus
politique pour régler le conflit israélo
palestinien c'est ce que demandent les
nations unies qui veulent éviter un
nouveau conflit après 11 jours
d'intenses affrontements entre le hamas
et l'armée israélienne un cessez le feu
est entré en vigueur vendredi dernier
mais sur le terrain les tensions
demeurent men attaque au couteau a fait
deux blessés dont un soldat israélien
jérusalem
l'assaillant a été abattu par les forces
de l'ordre
[Musique]
crise diplomatique entre la biélorussie
et plusieurs pays européens hier un
avion de ligne a atterri à minsk alors
qu'il devait rejoindre vilnius à son
bord un opposants biélorusses arrêtés
par les autorités locales
les chancelleries occidentales ont
unanimement condamné cette manoeuvre ce
soir les vingt-sept réunis en sommet
promettre une réponse forte
le récit d'hélène masquelier
détournement piraterie terrorisme
la biélorussie est acculé par la
communauté internationale en cause
l'interception d'un vol commercial
reliant athènes à vilnius par un avion
de chasse
suite à une alerte à la bombe supposé
pour un seul passager romane
protasiewicz 26 ans journaliste opposant
est attendu par les autorités locales
placé par minsk sur la liste des
individus impliqués dans des activités
terroristes
l'homme et sa petite amie sont arrêtés
un incident qui provoque l'indignation
d'une grande partie de la communauté
internationale
côté européen on juge cette intervention
inadmissible ce qui s'est passé hier est
un scandale international
nous travaillons sur des sanctions et
les sanctions seront sur la table du
conseil européen
une réaction ferme doite intervenir
suite aux événements qui se sont
déroulés hier
réaction également de washington qui
dénonce un acte choquant et une mise en
danger de la vie des passagers
seul soutien de la biélorussie moscou le
chef de la diplomatie russe juge
raisonnable la proche de minsk
de son côté londres assure difficile à
croire que moscou n'est pas donné son
accord
dans le même temps le pdg de ryanair
soupçonne la présence d'agents russes à
bord de l'appareil pour la biélorussie
l'équipage du vol a décidé seul sans
pression d'atterrir dans sa capitale
minsk qui assure que la menace visant
l'avion viendrait en réalité d'un email
du hamas nous soldats du hamas réclamant
qu'israël cesse le feu sur le secteur de
gaza
nous réclamons que l'union européenne
cesse son soutien à israël
si nos revendications ne sont pas
satisfaites une bombe explosera à bord
de l'avion ryanair au dessus de vilnius
après cette escale surprise l'avion est
reparti pour la capitale de la lituanie
mais vilnius ne compte pas en rester là
le parquet général a ouvert une enquête
pénale
une enquête a été ouverte conformément
au code pénal
fondée sur des motifs de crime
international d' enlèvement forcé et de
détournement d'avion le pays et d'autres
états européens ont convoqué les
ambassadeurs biélorusse ceux de l'otan
vont se réunir ce mardi une escale
imprévue qui n'a pas fini de troubler la
scène internationale le chef de la
diplomatie britannique dominic rabat a
affirmé aujourd'hui qu'il était
difficile de croire que moscou n'avait
pas donné son accord à ce détournement
de vols pourront parler ont rejoint
notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman pourquoi on verra quelle a été
la réaction des autorités russes par
rapport à cette affaire
bonsoir ses genoux la russie appelle à
ce que la situation avec le vol de
ryanair soit analysé non pas à la hâte
mais sur la base de toutes les
informations disponibles a déclaré le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov pour lui le fait que les
autorités
au pire le russe sommes prêtes à
collaborer avec des experts
internationaux révèle d'une approche
raisonnable je vous propose d'écouter
nous appelons à ce que cette situation
soit analysé non pas à la hâte dans la
précipitation mais sur la base de toutes
les informations disponibles
surtout que le porte parole du ministère
biélorusse des affaires étrangères a
fait une déclaration détaillée et a
souligné qu'en ce qui concerne cette
question
les autorités biélorusses étaient prêtes
à agir de manière transparente qu'elle
était disposée à se conformer à toutes
les règles internationales et à garantir
une transparence totale y compris si
ces serres en accueillant des experts
internationaux juniors
je pense que c'est une approche
absolument raisonnable je tiens à le
souligner une fois encore il est
important d'évaluer tout simplement
cette situation à tête reposée d'autant
plus que je le souligne une fois de plus
les autorités biélorusses sont prêtes à
fournir toutes les informations
nécessaires quant au porte-parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov il a déclaré qu'il
existait certaines règles
internationales et que ce sont là les
instances internationales qui doit
redonner une évolution et paiera les
autorités russes qui n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler d'autres affaires similaires
comme l'atterrissage forcé du président
bolivien c'était en 2013 oui
effectivement le mr russe des affaires
étrangères a publié une déclaration ce
soir où il détaillait justement les
incidents semblables et qui ont eu lieu
dans la pratique internationale comme
justement qu on vous l'avait dit
l'atterrissage forcé de l'avion du
président bolivien evo morales quand les
états unis ont fait de la pression sur
les ppe de et européens qui recherchait
à l'époque le lanceur d'alert edwards
snowdon quant à la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
malaise car dans ce communiqué justement
publié dans la soirée elle a insisté que
l'arrestation de rome en perte à cyril
était une affaire intérieure de la
biélorussie est appelé l'occident à
s'abstenir d'appliquer deux poids deux
mesures jouent propose d'écouter la
réaction coordonnée à ces événements de
la part des représentants d'un certain
nombre de pays occidentaux vous et
d'organisations internationales dont
l'union européenne l'otan et l'osce 6e
et surprenante ils exigent la libération
de romane protasiewicz et l'introduction
de sanctions supplémentaires
les plus sévères contre la biélorussie
la compagnie aérienne bellavia je
voudrais vous rappeler qu'ils ont réagi
différemment à des événements similaires
qui s'était auparavant produits dans
d'autres pays et il existe de nombreux
exemples de ce genre
je vous rappelle que selon les autorités
biélorusses l avion l dévié de sa
trajectoire à cause d'eux
laërt à la bombe les rapports de minsk a
affirmé que l' alerte à la bombe à
s'était révélé erroné
après une fouille de boeing le président
alexandre loukachenko a quant à lui
donné l'ordre personnellement à un avion
de chasse d'intercepter l'avion de ligne
après cette alerte a déclaré son service
de presse merci verhaeghe hoffman
correspondante à moscou et pour en
parler nous sommes avec jean de
gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'iris ancien diplomate français
bonsoir jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient de le voir dans ce sujet un acte
de piraterie d'état pour plusieurs états
européens dont d'ailleurs la france un
acte légal elle se défend minsk
qui croire dans cette affaire qui semble
à ses ruelles et sur réalise tout de
même je crois comme le dit le ministre
lavrov
il faut d'abord ton masse le maximum
d'informations précises parce que cette
affaire est quand même énorme et
consternantes
si véritablement c'est un détournement
d'avion c'est de la piraterie d'état ça
arrive de trois fois par siècle de trois
fois par siècle
l'exemple le plus marquant c'est en 1956
quand la quatrième république française
aux abois avait détourné un avion qui
partait de rabat pour capturer et une
partie de l'état-major du frr est à
l'époque la france avait été mise au ban
de la communauté internationale y avait
même l'opposition en france ça a été un
énorme scandale
donc si ces deux c'est de cet ordre là
c'est effectivement totalement
consternants ce que ça signifie aussi
c'est que si j'avais tab le mans ces
informations sont confirmées
ça signifie que l'état l'état de
biélorussie se moque de toute
considération internationale de toute
respectabilité au 1t retiens c'est qu'il
est aux abois comme l'était la quatrième
république française entre 1956 et donc
là aussi c'est très mauvais signe
enfin bien une dernière hypothèse qu'il
faut prendre en considération c'est que
il ya peu
une certaine autonomie des services de
sécurité qui fait que qui marque aussi
d'ailleurs une design certes un certain
discrédit un délitement du régime
je voudrais rajouter aussi une chose
c'est que le fait d'imputer au hamas une
bombe sur l'avion qui va vers la
lituanie s'est quasiment commis je
virerais on n'a pas besoin d'avoir fait
des études de droit international de
politologie pour s'imaginer que c'est
complètement faux en fait comme un peu
hamas peut-il à la rigueur s'il y avait
une bombe sur un avion partant d'israël
ça aurait eu un sens mais même le plus
obtus des chefs des services secrets
c'est bien que le hamas va pas mettre
pour régler un problème en palestine une
bombe entre deux sur l'avion entre la
lituanie et je parle il est parti de
pologne
oui quel prix pourquoi ne pas dans ce
cas assumer pour le bélarus parce que
c'est vrai que voilà mines se défend
l'équipage du vol à décider seul et sans
ingérence extérieure d'atterrir à minsk
il ya effectivement la sphère que vous
venez d'évoquer l'argument du hamas
pourquoi chercher des excuses et ne pas
assumer totalement les choses et ne pas
donner une explication claire mais parce
que c'est inadmissible je viens comme je
dis c'est 2 3 fois par siècle qu'un
étape détourne un avion un avion de
ligne régulière en dehors d'une période
de guerre
c'est honnêtement c'est vraiment énorme
jeu la réaction
c'est pour ça qu'on peut se demander
pourquoi ça arrive en ce moment la
veille du conseil européen en plus à ce
moment là des sanctions seront prises
nécessairement donc il ya encore une
fois on n'a peut-être pas tous les
éléments il ya des éléments qui ne de
keane qui n'apparaissent pas encore
clairement l'histoire du personnel qui a
débarqué de l'avion
quand on dit que ce sont des russes on a
parlé d'une altercation à bord de
l'avion dont il y avait ya des éléments
qui doivent être clarifiées ils le
seront mais si c'est un détournement
d'avion c'est quelque chose d'énorme
pour l'europe
il semblerait que la principale cause le
prétexte en tout cas la motivation de
minsk c'est cet opposant au régime
romane protasiewicz g de 26 ans ça vous
paraît crédible ce qu'il pèse autant
dans l'opposition ce jeune homme
en tout cas c'est sûr c'est que
maintenant il va peser très lourd
avant je ne sais pas en plus c'est un
pays de participer à une chaîne de
télévision ou de radio je me souviens
plus qui était dans l'opposition
est ce que ça vaut la peine de détourner
de faire un scandale international est
de détourner un avion pour capturer un
jeune homme de 26 ans qui a participé à
mecs tu as cette chaîne
je ne le pense pas encore une fois ça
donne l'impression d'une absence de
statut d'une sorte d' une sorte de
désordre intellectuelle dans ceux qui
ont pris ce genre de décision alors le
chef de la diplomatie britannique lui
affirme qu'il était difficile de croire
que moscou n est pas donné son accord à
ce détournement de deux vols de ryanair
ou quelle est votre réaction à cette
déclaration
ben on a tendance les chancelleries
occidentales et la presse occidentale
par l'ansa évidemment imputé ce genre
d'événement automatiquement aux russes
je pense que c'est enfin je ne sais pas
bien sûr personne ne sait mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que la biélorussie a
toujours revendiqué une autonomie de
décision et que le il y a un certain
nationalisme biélorusse qui en parfois
s'opposent même face aux russes et à la
russie et donc il n'est pas sûr du tout
que ça ne soit pas une initiative
autonome des biélorusses les russes là
je me sens
mais livré à ce type de manoeuvre
d'opérations de piraterie d'état
c'est quelque chose qu'une diplomatie
digne de ce nom ne pratique jamais que
les russes n'ont pas pratiqué donc si je
joue personnellement j'ai des doutes
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la
biélorussie va être au ban de la
communauté internationale elle a déjà
été dans le passé et que chaque fois
qu'elle était au banc de la communauté
internationale elle se elle se rapproche
de la russie qui est le le seul pays qui
la soutient un peu dans cette affaire
l'europe des vingt-sept réunis on le
disait en somme et promettre qu'il y
aura une réponse très forte de l'union
européenne à quoi doit-on s'attendre
c'est difficile à dire
il y a à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne un groupe de pays qui a
considéré jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'à
présent qu'il ne fallait pas sanctionner
gravement sur le plan économique la
biélorussie parce que ce faisant on la
poussait dans les bras de la russie je
pense que ce stade était passé et qui
aura sans doute des sanctions
économiques mais encore une fois je n'en
suis pas sûr je ne crois pas beaucoup sa
monture économique
il y aura sûrement en tout cas des
sanctions personnelles merci beaucoup
jean de gliniasty directeur de recherche
à l'iris ancien diplomate français merci
à vous le certificat numérique au vide
européen ou plus simplement le passé ni
terre et doit entrer en vigueur à partir
du 1er juillet pour faciliter les
voyages au sein de l'union européenne
malgré la pandémie
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite neige abderrazak en direct du
quai d'orsay bonsoir neige
l'union européenne qui ouvre dont 7
r à partir du 1er juillet sous
conditions
[Musique]
absolument stéphanie les vingt-sept se
sont mis d'accord sur la mise en place
d'un pass sanitaire européen pour
faciliter la reprise du tourisme le
document numérique ou en version papier
doit comporter trois possibilités
d'abord il doit attester qu'une personne
est vaccinée ou non alors qu'elle est
réalisé un test pcr négatif ou alors
qu'elle a contracté le kobe de 19 au
cours des six derniers mois
grand maximum fumée blanche
nous avons un accord sur la proposition
de la commission de certificats
numériques européens coe vide
nous avons abouti sur ce nouvel
instrument en un temps record pour
sauvegarder la libre circulation pour
tous les citoyens et tous les vaccins ne
sont pas reconnus par le passé sanitaire
européen pas le russe pas le chinois
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a affirmé ce
matin clément bonne il est secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
pour les vaccins du pass sanitaire
européen
ce sera tous les vaccins autorisés par
l' agence européenne des médicaments
il en a quatre nous serons très prudents
il n'est pas question qu'on arrive en
france avec un vaccin dont on n'est pas
sûr de la protection le russe ou le
chinois par exemple
et pourtant cela fait des mois que
spoutnik attend d'être homologués par
l'union européenne alors selon moscou
bruxelles retarderait volontairement
l'enregistrement de ce vaccin
veux pas blâmer les experts et
spécialistes de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments mais nous savons avec
certitude que ce retard est dû à des
signaux que leur donne des personnes
haut placées de l'union européenne et
nadège comment les hongrois vacciner au
spoutnik l'est par exemple on y être
reçue au sein des pays membres de
l'union en veine dont ils font partie
bah écoute et stéphanie ceux qui sont
déjà vaccinés au spoutnik vais par
exemple vont devoir et bien réalisé un
test un test négatif tests pcr négatif
pour pouvoir entrer dans certains pays
ou alors ils vont peut-être un et vous
c'est une éventualité de voir se faire
vacciner avec l'un des quatre vaccins
autorisés par l'union européenne alors
soit father astrazeneca moderna ou
encore johnson and johnson a si la
france a annoncé ne pas reconnaître les
vaccins russes et chinois on sait que ça
ne sera probablement pas le cas de tous
les pays de l'union européenne
merci nadège abderrazak alors le pass
annie terre s'il apparaît comme un outil
nécessaire aux déconfinement et à la
reprise du tourisme peut-il être aussi
une véritable arme géopolitique c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
joëlle mélin députée européenne pour le
rassemblement national à bonsoir madame
merci des marchés que nous en direct sur
rt france vous êtes un contre justement
se passa ni terre vous allez nous dire
pourquoi dans quelques instants à vos
côtés fassent avoue bruno m'égare ban
chef du service réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière et vous êtes pour se passer
ni terre vous allez vous aussi nous
expliquer vos raisons merci à tous les
deux d'être là alors pour commencer à
une réaction aux propos de clément bonin
le vaccin spoutnik v qui ne sera pas
reconnu par le passé ni terre européen
ça pose plein de questions on va aller
développer évidemment même chose pour le
vaccin chinois médicalement déjà bruno
megaman ça vous paraît justifiée écoutez
le vaccin spoutnik a publié ses
résultats dans la revue lancet tu pour
la phase iii
donc ces résultats avait l'air tout à
fait correcte avec une expérimentation
bien mené néanmoins il faut savoir que
dans les semaines qui ont suivi la
publication de cet article
certains scientifiques européens ont
contesté un certain nombre de ces
données notamment l'accès aux données a
été refusé par les auteurs ils ont
relevé un certain nombre de résultats
incohérents un changement au sein même
de l'étude avec une modification du
critère de jugement
quelques confusions concernant les
patients sélectionnés inclut les auteurs
d'ailleurs 2
russes ont répondu en disant
qu'effectivement il peut être il y avait
certaines erreurs typographiques dans
l'article néanmoins le vaccin spoutnik
donné de résultats favorables dans les
pays où il a été utilisé notamment en
argentine
donc on voit bien que je pense que le
vaccin est très probable on de qualité
malgré tout il ya encore quelques
incohérences lié peut-être à des
difficultés d'accès aux données par les
scientifiques
en tout cas le dossier scientifique est
actuellement en cours d'étude par l'
agence européenne du médicament en vue
d'obtenir une à mêmes éventuelles alors
il paraîtrait que il faut au moins
encore quelques semaines de plus et donc
là la réponse finale serait pour le mois
de juillet ce qui fait en fait que à ce
moment là effectivement l'europe aurait
suffisamment de doses d autres vaccins
actuellement à gré pour ne pas avoir à
recourir aux vaccins spoutnik
ce d'autant plus que les capacités de
production de ce vaccin sont limitées
donc on voit bien qu effectivement il y
a à la fois un problème administratif
un problème peut-être scientifique ou
certaines zones d'ombré persistent et
peut-être même on peut pas l'écarter un
problème de géopolitique
effectivement mais là c'est étonnant
parce qu'on rappelle quand même que plus
de 57 pays utilisent le vaccin russe an
sans compter les nombreux qui utilisent
le vaccin chinoise que clairement on est
en train de faire de de la politique et
même de la géopolitique dans cette
affaire on en avait beaucoup parlé déjà
à l'époque où thierry breton avait fait
sa sortie prévenons il ya déjà plusieurs
semaines qu'on en aurait pas besoin
d'autres vaccins russe en europe
oui bien écouté mon goût frère qui est
encore plus qualifiés que moi pour avoir
accès aux toutes les études en cours
vous a parfaitement démontré qu'il
s'agit d'un problème purement politique
les mains a été saisie je crois fin
février ou début mars de la demande de
soutenir du spoutnik i fait ses preuves
ailleurs
comme tous les autres d'ailleurs une
réelle incertitude quant à l'efficacité
on a manifestement des résultats
encourageants on ne peut pas aller
contre tout cela mais il ya quand même
une part d'incertitude et l'attitude
européenne qui consiste à retarder
précisément au moment même où les
chaînes de production qui ont été aidés
par les préachats européen et toutes les
subventions européennes de l'an dernier
tous ses chaînes de production vont être
à plat dont faire en sorte que nous
n'aurons pas forcément besoin d'une
route nique
il s'agit là d'une utilisation de la
santé à des fins politiques qui à titre
personnel me choque profondément
je crois que si on aurait pu vacciner
plus de français mais même dans tout le
monde beaucoup plus de personnes avec
les autres vaccins que ce soit le
spoutnik que ce soit le sinopharm ou
même d'autres possibilités qu'ils ont et
de fait la preuve
toujours pareil avec la marge d'erreur
dans d'autres pays on aurait dû pouvoir
le faire c'est tout à fait inadmissible
et là je trouve que vous part sur une
instrumentalisation de la santé mais
nous en parlons peut-être tout à l'heure
elle est aussi totalement
instrumentalisée honneur au niveau
européen avec tous les nouveaux textes
que nous sommes en train de travailler
et bien évidemment avec la résultante
quand cet épisode là sera passée une
énorme bourde de donner une banque de
données du vivant de tout ce qu'il ya de
plus intime de la personne
à propos de la santé et là on part dans
des domaines où l'europe a prouvé
qu'elle ne pouvait pas vraiment pas
sécuriser ses données
bruno megaman cerexhe que souligne joël
mais là on rappelle quand même que c'est
vexant russe
on savait susciter pas mal de moqueries
à l'époque mais enfin il est disponible
quand même depuis août dernier 1 depuis
l'été ça veut dire concrètement en quoi
sans vous faire dire ce que ce que vous
ne pouvez pas dire parce qu'on n'a pas
de preuves bien évidemment mais enfin on
aurait peut-être pu sauver des vies on
se rend compte aujourd'hui vous c'est
pas compliqué 1,2 de voir un petit peu
la main d'oeuvre qui consiste à dire
voilà bastien trop tard vint donc vous
avez l'autorisation on n'a plus besoin
de vous alors je dirais bon à mon niveau
je ne peux pas donner d'informations
concernant évidemment les raisons de
d'achat ou de ne pas de ne pas avoir
acheté ce sens malgré tout
vous êtes voilà tout simplement n'ai pas
de raison de penser que ce vaccin ne
soit pas efficace pour prévenir les
formes graves de lakovic 19 et ne soit
pas suffisamment efficace pour réduire
la circulation du virus alors il est
vrai que l'europe au départ avaient misé
sur d'autres vaccins il est vrai aussi
que les capacités de production du
vaccin spoutnik par la russie sont assez
limités et donc finalement obtenir les
vaccins venant des des fournisseurs
agréés pour le moment par l'agencé du
médicament est peut-être plus simple que
de faire appel à la russie maintenant
moi je suis confiant je crois que si
l'europe ne l'utilisent pas les vaccins
russe il ya suffisamment d'individus sur
la planète qui ont besoin de vaccination
est bien comme utilisent ce vaccin très
probablement efficace pour vacciner
protéger tous ces humains car évidemment
comme tout le monde le sait nous ne
pouvons nous débarrasser de la pandémie
quand vaccinant la totalité de
l'humanité
alors il ya aussi les questions
économiques là je m'adresse à la députée
européenne que vous êtes content on sait
ce que représente les touristes chinois
l'été pour le tourisme en france qui a
bien besoin qu'on lui redonne un petit
coup voilà deux fois est ce que c'est
c'est judicieux cette sortie du
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes parce qu'il n'ya pas que le
vaccin besson le rappelle est aussi les
vaccins chinois ça fait beaucoup monde a
écouté le souci qu'on a avec les
politiques à l'heure actuelle c'est
qu'ils sont dans un dogmatisme
totalement réducteur
j'entends bien qu'on tout le monde a
envie de devoir aller et venir et
surtout à la veille de l'été donc on
puisse se trouver avec un passeport tel
qu'il est appelé mais tout simplement un
signe que l'on n'ait pas contaminants de
part et d'autre de frontières puisque on
a choisi les frontières comme
moi voilà maintenant plusieurs mois que
vacciner pas vaccinés au départ et
maintenant vaccinée
j'arrive en belgique avec mon q r comme
je suis allé au luxembourg avec mon cul
vers code ya rien de très compliqué là
dedans
si ce qui est compliqué c'est quand on
fera le compte du coût global de tous
les tests parce que à titre personnel
utilisant une sécurité sociale
communautaire et non française je paye
mon test cash
il est à plus de 50 euros à chaque fois
donc je pense pas que la sécurité
sociale puisse de tous les pays
d'ailleurs puissent très longtemps à
aborder ce foot là d'ailleurs ça a été
une des discussions dans le cadre du
texte que nous voterons au mois de juin
ce que je crois si vous voulez c'est que
la réduction ad simplement des
dogmatismes du centre au tourisme nous
avait pas beaucoup de retard un exemple
simple du mega man sera sans doute
d'accord avec moi le varia anglais
connue depuis le 1er octobre nous aurons
débarrassions très difficilement en
europe continentale d'élus juin entre
nous soit dit là les vols avec l'un
d'eux sont complètement ouvert vous
pouvez aller venir comme vous voulez
france inde en france tous les vols sont
ouverts et il n'y a pas de quarantaine à
la sortie et ils ce sont les quarantaine
de volontaires
je crois que les chefs qui contrarierait
les gens qui sont celles de faire des
quarantaines / dpi
comment avec des variantes très
compliqué ou du moins plus potache et
donc avec toutes les conséquences qu'on
connaît mais aussi obliger tout un
chacun positif à ce s'isoler réellement
et il faut le dire fermement
pendant les dix jours nécessaires
couperet encore plus au delà de la
vaccination la des précautions
je dois dire que les français ont
vraiment été très raisonnable jusqu'à
l'ouverture de 10 du confinement ces
jours ci il ya quand même eu une
réaction nationale qui a été de très
très belles qualités
et pourtant nous avons encore douze à
quinze mille cas par jour
je rappelle que l'an dernier nous avons
des confiner le 11 mai
l'épidémie a redémarré le 16 juin alors
moi j'étais dans la région marseillaise
il y avait ce fameux variant marseillais
qui était un petit peu particulier mais
le 16 juin tout à redémarrer
donc il faut que nous soyons très
prudent et qu'on arrête avoir du dôme
10 mhz politique quand il s'agit de
redonner une vie normale à tous les
français tous les européens et même à
toute la planète on peut pas continuer
comme ça évidemment on peut pas monsieur
megaman et est en réanimation il sait le
coût de la vie et les modalités du soin
qu'on doit donner et puis tous ceux qui
ne peuvent pas bénéficier des services
de rien hormis évidemment effectivement
là n'osait vous faisiez allusion se
passe en terre qu'on utilisera
spécifiquement en france parce qu'il
faut distinguer le parce qu'on utilisera
à partir du 1er juillet dans toute
l'europe les le passé ni terre pour les
événements de plus de mille personnes en
partir du 9 juin qui a été approuvé par
le sénat français ce qui ne plaît pas
tous les députés qui sont opposés comme
la député du bas-rhin martin venait
avant de vous faire réagir je voudrais
vous faire écouter
sept députés le sénat s'est de
gouvernement la mise en place du pass
sanitaire covit 19 sur notre territoire
restreindre les libertés des français
est une décision politique et non
sanitaires aucune preuve n'est apportée
quant à la nécessité du pass aucune
preuve quant à la nécessité du pass
bruno m'égare ban qu'en pense le médecin
que vous êtes mais écoutez le pass a été
réservée aux rassemblements de plus de
1000 personnes notamment dans des
festivals temps des réunions culturelles
ou sportives ou effectivement par
définition il ya un brassage de
personnes venant d'horizons différentes
qui ne se connaissent pas qui vont être
côte à côte qui vont se parler crier
chanter
donc effectivement malheureusement même
site c'est en lieux ouverts
il existe un risque de contamination
aujourd'hui le virus n'a pas disparu
circulent encore un niveau relativement
important trois fois plus que le niveau
qui serait nécessaire pour pouvoir
permettre des dépistages et des traçages
efficace et donc il faut être
extrêmement prudent
donc je crois que c'est en fait
paradoxalement pas du tout un moyen
d'empêcher la liberté mais au contraire
de permettre la reprise en sécurité de
certaines activités notamment avec ses
fameux rassemblement
par ailleurs je suis convaincu
effectivement que ce pass pourra aussi
jouer un rôle important pour inciter
notamment les
jeunes à se faire vacciner donc tous les
moyens sont bons on le voit qu'un à
nouveau ce que la vaccination le niveau
de vaccination va déterminer aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui va se passer en septembre
octobre
si la population adulte notamment les
jeunes ne sont pas suffisamment de
vacciné malheureusement en septembre
octobre on risquerait de voir à nouveau
le virus repartir et à ce moment là
toutes les personnes non vaccinées
courir un risque de faire des formes
graves
mais comme à ce moment là évidemment la
vie aura repris normalement comme bien
sûr il sera totalement impossible
d'imposer des restrictions car les
vacciner ne le comprendraient pas eh
bien ces personnes prendraient d'un
risque direct pour eux mêmes de faire
une forme grave et de décéder
joëlle mélin ce sont quand même des
arguments de bon sens qu'est ce que vous
répondez vous qui êtes on s'est opposé à
ce pas de sanitaires à titre personnel
je parlerai plus à titre personnel mais
même un petit peu plus largement dans le
mouvement dans lequel je suis
nous sommes contre ce pass numérique
je ne vois aucune difficulté comme je le
fais moi encore une fois depuis des mois
comme tous mes collègues toutes les
personnes avec qui je voyage dans le
train dans l'avion d'avoir un document
papier qrcode d'avoir le bon vieux
certificat cette vaccination le carnet
de vaccination l'international jaune et
noir ce n'est absolument pas ça et je
partage l'avis de mon confrère quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé hier soir à
lille on peut se dire que compte tenu du
nombre de personnes statistiquement
évidemment dans les jours dans les dix
jours qui vont venir on va avoir
qu'apparaître parc de ci de là de
nouveaux cas pour les rassemblements
cela me semble normal qu'il faut pas
confondre ceux qui se les clés proposés
au plan médical et qui est tout à fait
recevable de pouvoir aller dans des
grandes réunions avec la certitude que
vous êtes testées négatives avec les la
marge de manoeuvre de d'erreurs que l'on
connait on est maintenant on sait que
c'est pas tout à fait à 100 % mais sa
limite sérieusement quand même la
contamination et le fait d'avoir un pass
sanitaire qui serait un pass
prétendument passe
or éternelle ce qu'ils font on va se
trouver avec un vaccin qui va ressembler
à ceux de la grippe donc il n'est
valable que six à huit mois je m'appelle
quand même si les informations sont bâle
qui a quand même plus de 500 personnes à
marseille qui était largement vacciner
et qui ont contracté un virus mutant
évidemment c'est un peu comme si nous
avions plusieurs épidémies à la fois
cousine mais un petit peu différente à
chaque fois
donc évidemment il faut se protéger et
effectivement ça poussera tout le monde
à se vacciner rapidement
encore faut-il pour cela qu'on est la
production et là il ya eu toute une
sorte de mensonges de promesses
mensongères faites alors là au plan
politique par les allemands pendant leur
présidence de dire qu'on allait avoir le
vaccin pour noël nous on est l'accès à
un témoin comme un petit peu et on n'a
pas toujours attendu les fans phase iii
comme le spoutnik l'avait fait en russie
pour pouvoir commencer à vacciner
largement ce qui nous a fait gagner du
temps les phases 2 et 3 qui sont un peu
superposés mais on n'avait pas les
chaînes de production des chaînes de
production se met efficace j'entends
pour avoir suffisamment de vaccins pour
tout le monde
elle se met en place la queue depuis
avril mais évidemment il aurait mieux
fallu tenir au champ on vaccine
c'est ce qu'on a fait d'ailleurs et les
autres attendent et fait attention on
vous promet pas on va faire des
vaccinodromes avant l'heure et autres ça
c'est les politiques qui l'ont fait au
niveau local s'était pas tout à fait
raisonnable et honnête à l'égard des
gens il faut bien vraiment con soir
médicaux protecteur hélas oui monsieur
mais garbage artistes partagent votre
avis sur le fait qu'il faut dans les
rassemblements avoir un qi reconnaît qu
un code ou même un test négatif papier
ça ira très bien aussi
merci beaucoup à tous les deux en tout
cas d'avoir exprimé ses arguments à l'un
et l'autre joëlle mélin bruno mais
regarde ma mère fait d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur le détournement d'un avion par la
biélorussie il y aura une réponse très
forte de l'union européenne promet
ursula von der leyen agences onusiennes
de l'aviation civile annoncent elles une
réunion d'urgence jeudi
oui retour sur le conflit entre
israélien et le hamas le cessez-le-feu
perturbé après une attaque au couteau
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et en donne
séparation que la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police qui serait son travail
c'est plus compliqué que ça on est
français on est fiers de vivre dans ces
quartiers même si à des difficultés et
la moindre des choses c'est d'inscrire
aussi notre empreinte canton quand on
participe à la vie de la société et
malheureusement n'y a pas cette
reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'imposant
l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chier boxart y allons
faire connaissance vous avez choisi le
jour à ba et là on est
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois que la france
était en 2011 le monde manque pas un
petit peu non ah oui et c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h48 les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez la
situation reste tendue au proche orient
à jérusalem une attaque au couteau a
fait deux blessés aujourd'hui près d'une
station de tramway
parmi eux un soldat israélien
l'assaillant palestiniens étaient
abattus par la police israélienne
une attaque alors qu'un cessez le feu
est entré en vigueur vendredi dernier
une trêve après 11 jours d'affrontements
entre le hamas et l'armée israélienne
dans la bande de gaza les dégâts
matériels et humains sont conséquents
une mission de l'onu s'est rendue sur
place pour évaluer c'est dommage
les nations unies appellent à une vérité
un véritable processus politique pour
régler les causes du conflit
israélo-palestinien éviter qu'ils ne
reprennent grâce à ya plus de 240 morts
en onze jours
c'est le triste bilan des frappes entre
gaza et jérusalem à jérusalem des colons
juifs sont entrés dans l'enceinte de la
mosquée al aqsa troisième site le plus
sacré de l'islam sous la protection de
la police israélienne alors que des
fidèles musulmans priaient sur le lieu
sans une incursion vécu comme une
provocation
nous sommes venus aujourd'hui d'une
offre pour effectuer la prière de midi à
la mosquée al aqsa mais nous avons été
surpris par l'entrée des colons après
tout ce qui s'est passé et les disputes
pour les empêcher l'entrée à l'aise il
entre toujours dans la mosquée al aqsa
sans notre approbation et avec le refus
de tous c'est une provocation et une
quatrième guerre entre les deux camps
qui laisse la communauté internationale
impuissante
côté humanitaire c'est la même chose les
aides de terrain font face à la détresse
quotidienne des familles
un message que j'ai entendu à plusieurs
reprises c'est que la population de gaza
est plus traumatisée que jamais figard
sont femmes et hommes
l'intensité des frappes étaient sans
répit trop de maisons ont été détruites
et des êtres chers sont partis de
nombreuses personnes m'ont dit qu'elle
se sentait impuissante et même
désespèrent
et ils n'ont aucun contrôle sur leur vie
les parents disent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
rassuré leurs enfants en leur disant que
cela n'arrivera plus comment le pourrais
t'on après tant de guerre des enjeux
humanitaires mais aussi diplomatiques
car si le cessez le feu entre le hamas
et israël est entré en vigueur vendredi
il ne fixe pour l'heure aucune condition
à l'arrêt des combats
l'onu appelle à régler les causes
profondes du conflit dans la période à
venir je rappellerai à la communauté
internationale que les causes profondes
du conflit demeure l'occupation les
déplacements forcés dont nous avons eu
un fort appel à cheikh jarrah
dernièrement le blocus et le cycle de la
violence demeure tout cela doit être
résolu un conflit non résolu est comme
un volcan qui entre en éruption de façon
intermittente et détruit tous ceux qui
l'entourent puis se calme
c'est ce que ressent gaza pour moi quant
aux pays voisins
il tente d'aider au mieux l'egypte qui
s'est posé en médiateur a fait parvenir
plusieurs camions dead par le poste
frontière de rafah dans le sud de la
bande de gaza aux états unis on appelle
les deux camps à la retenue
je crois que les palestiniens et les
israéliens méritent tous deux de vivre
en sécurité et de jouir des mêmes
mesures de liberté de prospérité du
démocratie mon gouvernement poursuivra
sa diplomatie discrète et implacable à
cette fin je pense que nous avons une
réelle opportunité de faire des progrès
et je m'engage à travailler dans ce sens
à l'international les manifestations
continuent à se multiplier
alors que de nombreux rassemblements
pro-palestiniens ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours à travers le monde
dimanche à londres et ailleurs ils
étaient des milliers
manifester leur solidarité avec israël
depuis le 10 mai 248 palestiniens et 12
israéliens ont perdu la vie et pour plus
de précisions nous retrouvons tout de
suite paul ailleurs journaliste pour rt
internationale en direct de tel-aviv
bonsoir paula merci d'être avec nous
quelle est l'atmosphère sur place à tel
aviv ses locaux tour au calme dans les
rues
mais s pizza maintenant on essaie dé
retour à la normalité et depuis il n'y a
d'ailleurs deux heures du matin sur
place vendredi matin
c'est à ce moment là que le cessez le
feu est entré en effet et la vie est
bien évidemment revenu à la normale nous
sommes au centre du pays au dessus de
distraire cela a pris un peu plus de
temps mais maintenant la vie de retour à
la normal là bas également et les
israéliens fait de la frontière sont
retournés chez eux
les éclats sont couvertes les commerces
sont ouverts l'appuyer de retour pour
les gazaouis c'est également plus ou
moins la même chose il ya eu davantage
de destruction de bâtiments et de
logements beaucoup de gazaouis n ont pas
encore de logements
c'est beaucoup d'entre eux une seule
donc à la recherche de logements
temporaires dans des écoles et un des
bâtiments de l'onu ainsi que deux
secours humanitaires ou des bâtiments
gouvernementaux
les écoles ne rouvriront pas à gaza
avant la résolution de la situation le
retour à une normalité
car les classes certes encore de refuge
pour beaucoup de personnes
maintenant à la situation humanitaire à
gaza tout comme je vais évoquer beaucoup
de personnes qui ont perdu leur maison
les nations unies de nom de plus belle
ensuite le [ __ ] à giffa principal de
gaza rayons que de matériel médical et a
besoin d'être margaritis qui maintient
majorité des biens humanitaires qui
entrent à gaza depuis israël par le
carrefour de carême h à l'homme qui a
été rouvert après des fermetures
sporadiques à cause des tirs de
roquettes à proximité continue de peiner
au carrefour et confère l requins
rentrer un veau dans gaza donc la
situation est à nouveau normale paul à
la trêve est tout de même fragile n'est
ce pas entre les deux camps avec un
incident d'ailleurs bottes dans la
journée
tout à fait il ya eu quelques incidents
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du cessez le
feu ce vendredi après midi après les
coups de midi
il ya eu des heures pendant deux heures
dans la mosquée de al aksa se certains
jeunes pas la majorité où certains
jeunes sont entrés en confrontation avec
les officiers de sécurité israéliens sur
place ils envoyaient des pierres des
cocktails molotov
la collégiale la police et l'armée a
riposté avec des gaz lacrymogènes et des
grenades assourdissantes
j'ai résister à de nombreuses reprises
la frontière entre gaza et israël depuis
vendredi le flou tient mais la grande
question c'est pendant combien de temps
le hamas d'avoir remporté ce conflit a
man et on reconstruit la fierté
palestinienne on ayant des visages
howling passerelle juin côté il serait
bien prétend également avoir obtenu la
victoire car il aurait détruit par une
part suffisante autorités et aux
équipements militaires du hamas
je parle ici de spéculations et de
commentaires officieux il faudrait il
avoir une nouvelle confrontation une
nouvelle guerre ici car il ya sept ans
il ya des gels une guerre entre hamas et
israël
la plupart des gens sont d'accord pour
dire que il n'est qu'une question de
temps avant d'en avoir encore une autre
merci paul à slayer journée et ce pour
rt internationale en direct de tel aviv
et pour approfondir le sujet nous sommes
avec claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
soie rose blanche maison avec le recul
de ces quatre jours de cessez le feu
qu'elle voir sans présence tire le plus
de profit politique cessez le feu qui
s'est mis en place vendredi matin marque
d'abord la fin de ce que antonio
guterres yes le secrétaire général de
l'onu avait qualifié d' enfer sur la
terre pour les enfants de gaza cela dit
le sur le plan politique le groupe qui
en tire le principal profit est sans
doute le hamas puisqu'il s'est posé
depuis le début de cette crise comme le
principal défenseur de la mosquée al
aqsa qui est le troisième lieu saint de
l'islam comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dans votre sujet et puis il a
marginalisé mahmoud abbas et le fatah
qui dans le fond à ramallah n'ont pas pu
faire grand chose
cela dit le fatah et monsieur mahmoud al
mahmoud abbas donc en quelque sorte
prendre leur revanche
cette semaine puisque anthony blinken va
leur rendre visite et quand tony blinken
ne peut pas rendre visite aux
terroristes entre guillemets du hamas là
le deuxième bénéficiaire de cette crise
c'est probablement le monsieur netanyahu
lui même personnellement puisque
vis-à-vis ses électeurs il est apparu
comme l'homme fort d'israël qui est
capable de défense d'israël contre les
terroristes toujours votre guillemets et
qui finalement se montre suffisamment
fort et qui par conséquent doit rester à
la à la tête d'un gouvernement israélien
or comme vous le savez il était
incapable de former un nouveau
gouvernement et l'opposition est dans le
même état
donc soit il trouvera une formule il
sera probablement avec les gens de
l'extrême droite israélienne
soit il faudra retourner à de nouvelles
élections
le troisième bénéficiaire c'est sans
doute le président égyptien
si si qui a joué un rôle déterminant
dans la médiation pour aboutir à ce
cessez le feu
puisque lui a des rapports très anciens
avec israël on se souvient que l'egypte
a négocié sont ses rapports avec israël
il ya très longtemps mais il parle aussi
ils continuent ils à des rapports avec
la masse donc avec les deux côtés qui
est également le cas de la jordanie qui
a normalisé ses relations avec israël un
peu plus tard mais il y as quand même
pas mal d'à pas mal d'années et qui a
toujours des relations avec le hamas
ce qui n'est pas le cas des pays arabes
qui ont été poussés par donald trump
leur désaccord d'abraham à normaliser
leurs relations avec israël mais il y
avait une petite condition un codicille
pas de rapport avec le hamas
peut-être peut-on dire aussi que à bien
moindre degré l'un des bénéficiaires
indirects seraient le président erdogan
puisqu'il s'est à nouveau posée comme le
défenseur de l'islam dans le monde
contre contre israël les ceux qui ont
finalement sont peut-être les perdants
c'est d'abord à mon avis joe biden qui
dans le fond pour sa première crise
diplomatique a éprouvé beaucoup de
difficultés le président netanyahu a
résisté à cinq coups de fil du président
les états unis la principale puissance
du monde
le principal allié et bien sans effet et
finalement le président byden envoie son
secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken pour discuter avec
israël est elle assurée de de son
soutien je crois que parmi les autres
victimes de 2,7 et on court on pourrait
dire aussi qu'il ya l'union européenne
dans la mesure où l'union européenne
continue ses divisions n'a pas pu faire
grand chose qu'elle a attendu avant de
prendre clairement position
elle avait implicitement accepter le
report des élections qui avaient décidé
mahmoud abbas parce qu'il craignait une
victoire du hamas
et dans le fond elle n'était pas en
position d'exercer quelques médiation
que ce soit aujourd'hui elle va être
convoqué bien sûr comme toujours
pour la reconstruction de la bande de
gaza merci claude blanchemaison pour ses
explications et à gaza l'heure est à la
reconstruction les dégâts sont
évidemment très important reportage de
mon staff à al bayda avec solène gaudin
auprès d'une famille palestinienne
décimée par cette guerre aucun membre de
la famille al hadidi n'a survécu sauf un
père et son bébé qui n'a même pas six
mois la maison de quatre étages qui
appartenait à la famille a été détruite
après les raids israéliens contre le
camp d'achat ti la défensive il est
temps démunis sortir les corps des
victimes des décombres s'est avéré très
difficile
par miracle le père et son bébé ont été
sauvés je m'adresse au monde libre of
assis devant son écran de télévision je
me demande ses enfants quel crime ont
ils commis
quel est le crime pour lequel ils sont
bombardés par des avions et ciblés par
des tirs de roquettes se sont vraiment
eux qui ont lancé des missiles ou qui
figure sur la liste des personnes
recherchées c'est un crime contre
l'humanité le plus grand crime qui doit
être sanctionné par la loi avant de
demander justice à la communauté
internationale je m'adresse à au ciel
allah le tout puissant et grands
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de justice surtout
le bébé était dans les bras de sa mère
tuée avec ses trois fils le raid
israélien a fait dix morts dont huit
enfants anna d'origine de finale quel
que soit le rôle du père il ne peut pas
remplacer la mère son rôle est
fondamental
elles élèvent les enfants elles seront
soin d'eux après le bombardement les
sauveteurs m'ont dit qu'ils avaient
trouvé l'enfant dans les bras de sa mère
décédée
quels soins manifesté par sa mère
qu'allah lui fasse miséricorde
waouh
de nombreuses familles ont été rayés des
listes du registre d'état civil
après avoir été tuées lors des raids la
famille alcoolique dans laquelle 16
personnes sont mortes n'est pas la
moindre
les habitants de la bande de gaza ont
toujours pensé que les avions de combat
israéliens visaient délibérément des
bâtiments résidentiels et que leur
maison
on n'était que des cibles israéliennes
pour punir les habitants de gaza
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur le vol des tournées
hier par la biélorussie receneurs von
der leyen qui annonce une réponse forte
de l'union européenne réunis ce soir en
sommet et puis nous parlerons de la
réaction d'audrey pulvar en france elle
porte plainte à son tour contre le
ministre de l'intérieur l'accusant de
diffamation pour ses propos sur la
manifestation policière tenue à paris
mercredi
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois que la france était en 2011 le
monde manque pas un petit peu non ah oui
c'est tous les fromages tous les soucis
sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît que l'amitié les
gens les gens très stylé fallu les
français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge et
autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
à très bientôt sur arte et france
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il sous ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui révèle il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
ça
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique non une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage de ces
vaccins là c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le convive 19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires à l'étranger
que ça soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition-là
devoir amener l'agenda de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
oh
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoindre en direct pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de ce lundi 24 mai
l'ordre du jour du sommet européen qui a
débuté tout à l'heure chamboulée depuis
l'interception hier par la biélorussie
d'un avion de ligne transportant un
ancien collaborateur d'une chaîne
d'opposition minsk affirme avoir agi
dans son droit waucampt une alerte à la
bombe
moss ou réagi ce soir et demandent
davantage d' enquête bruxelles dénonce
un comportement scandaleux et illégal
l'union européenne annonce une réponse
très forte agences onusiennes de
l'aviation civile tiendra une réunion
d'urgence jeudi à peine à
l'expérimentation voté l assemblée le
112 déjà décrié le numéro unique d'appel
d'urgence censées fusionner le 17 18 et
le 15 ans ne fait pas l'unanimité dans
une tribune publiée hier dans le jdd
près de 200 signataires alerte contre
cette mesure qu'ils jugent inefficace et
rappelle que seul un médecin est capable
de définir avec l'appelant la gravité de
la situation médicale une plainte après
l'autre audrey pulvar a répondu
aujourd'hui elle annonce de plaintes de
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui accuse de diffamer la
police la tête de liste des socialistes
aux élections régionales en
ile-de-france avait jugé le site assez
glaçant la manifestation policière
devant l'assemblée nationale mercredi
dernier aux états unis commémoration à
minneapolis du premier anniversaire de
la mort de georgia floyd environ 1500
personnes ont marché en la mémoire de
cet afro américain décédé sous les
genoux d'un policier pour réclamer un
changement au sein des forces de l'ordre
derek sherwin a été reconnu coupable de
meurtre
20 avril dernier sera fixée sur sa peine
le 25 juin
[Musique]
crise diplomatique donc entre la
biélorussie et plusieurs pays européens
hier un avion de ligne a atterri à minsk
alors qu'il devait rejoindre vilnius à
son bord un opposants biélorusses
arrêtés par les autorités locales
les chancelleries occidentales ont
unanimement condamné cette manoeuvre ce
soir les vingt-sept réunis en sommet
promettent une réponse forte
le récit des leds masquelier
détournement piraterie terrorisme
la biélorussie est acculé par la
communauté internationale en cause
l'interception d'un vol commercial
reliant athènes à vilnius par un avion
de chasse
suite à une alerte à la bombe supposé
pour un seul passager romane
protasiewicz 26 ans journaliste opposant
est attendu par les autorités locales
placé par minsk sur la liste des
individus impliqués dans des activités
terroristes
l'homme et sa petite amie sont arrêtés
un incident qui provoque l'indignation
d'une grande partie de la communauté
internationale
côté européen on juge cette intervention
inadmissibles qui s'est passé hier est
un scandale international une
travaillons sur des sanctions et les
sanctions seront sur la table du conseil
européen
une réaction ferme doivent intervenir
suite aux événements qui se sont
déroulés hier
réaction également de washington qui
dénonce un acte choquant et une mise en
danger de la vie des passagers
seul soutien de la biélorussie moscou le
chef de la diplomatie russe juge
raisonnable la proche de minsk
de son côté londres assure difficile à
croire que moscou n'est pas donné son
accord
dans le même temps le pdg de ryanair
soupçonne la présence d'agents russes à
bord de l'appareil pour la biélorussie
l'équipage du vol a décidé seul sans
pression d'atterrir dans sa capitale
minsk qui assure que la menace visant
l'avion viendrait en réalité d'un email
du hamas nous soldats du hamas réclamant
qu'israël cesse le feu sur le secteur de
gaza
nous réclamons que l'union européenne
cesse son soutien à israël
si nos revendications ne sont pas
satisfaites une bombe explosera à bord
de l'avion ryanair au dessus de vilnius
après cette escale surprise l'avion est
reparti pour la capitale de la lituanie
mais vilnius ne compte pas en rester là
le parquet général a ouvert une enquête
pénale
une enquête a été ouverte conformément
au code pénal
fondée sur des motifs de crime
international d' enlèvement forcé et de
détournement d'avion le pays et d'autres
états européens ont convoqué les
ambassadeurs biélorusse ceux de l'otan
vont se réunir ce mardi une escale
imprévue qui n'a pas fini de troubler la
scène internationale le chef de la
diplomatie britannique dominic rabat
affirmé aujourd'hui qu'il était
difficile de croire qu moscou n'est pas
donné son accord à ce détournement du
vol pour en parler en juin notre
correspondante à moscou vera goffman
soir verra quelle a été la réaction des
autorités russes par rapport à cette
affaire
bonsoir stéphanie la russie appelle à ce
que la situation avec le vol de ryanair
soit analysé non pas à la hâte mais sur
la base de toutes les informations
disponibles a déclaré ce matin le chef
de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
pour lui le fait que les autorités
biélorusses sont prêtes à collaborer
avec des experts internationaux révèle
d'une approche est raisonnable je vous
propose d'écouter
nous appelons à ce que cette situation
soit analysé non pas à la hâte dans la
précipitation mais sur la base de toutes
les informations disponibles
surtout que le porte parole du ministère
biélorusse des affaires étrangères a
fait une déclaration détaillée et a
souligné qu'en ce qui concerne cette
question
les autorités biélorusses étaient prêtes
à agir de manière transparente qu'elle
était disposée à se conformer à toutes
les règles internationales et à garantir
une transparence totale y compris si
nécessaire
en accueillant des experts
internationaux juniors
je pense que c'est une approche
absolument raisonnable je tiens à le
souligner une fois encore il est
important d'évaluer tout simplement ses
petits
tu as sion à tête reposée d'autant plus
que je le souligne une fois de plus les
autorités biélorusses sont prêtes à
fournir toutes les informations
nécessaires
le porte parole du kremlin dmitri peskov
il a déclaré qu'il existait certaines
règles internationales et que ce sont
les instances aériennes internationales
qui doivent donner une évolution et
verra les autorités russes qui n'ont pas
manqué de rappeler dans trois affaires
similaires comme l'atterrissage forcé du
président bolivien c'était en 2013 oui
et tout à fait dans une déclaration
publiée dans la soirée par le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères
on était justement une série d'incidents
semblables qui ont eu lieu dans la
pratique internationale comme vous
l'avez dit l'atterrissage forcé de
l'avion du président bolivien evo
morales en 2013
à l'époque les états unis ont fait
pression sur les états européens pour
que l'avion a dû président bolivien
atterrissent en autriche à l'époque
justement les autorités étasuniennes
rechercher le lanceur d'alert edwards
synodale et pour revenir un peu sur la
déclaration du ministère russe s'est
marié zacharo braqué a insisté que
l'arrestation de vendin de patassé était
une affaire intérieure de la biélorussie
et a appelé l'occident à cette ligne
d'appliquer deux poids deux mesures
écoutez la réaction coordonnée à ces
événements de la part des représentants
d'un certain nombre de pays occidentaux
vous et d'organisations internationales
dont l'union européenne l'otan et l'osce
6e et surprenants ils exigent la
libération de romane protasiewicz et
l'introduction de sanctions
supplémentaires
les plus sévères contre la biélorussie
la compagnie aérienne bellavia je
voudrais vous rappeler qu'ils ont réagi
différemment à des événements similaires
qui s'était auparavant produits dans
d'autres pays et il existe de nombreux
exemples de ce genre
nous appelons nos partenaires
occidentaux à s'abstenir d'appliquer
deux poids deux mesures et à prendre des
mesures pour évaluer sobrement sans
émotion la situation sur la base de tous
les documents disponibles en coopération
avec les autorités aéronautiques
biélorusse qui font preuve de
transparence et de volonté de coopérer
et je vous rappelle que selon les
autorités biélorusses l'avion a dévié de
sa trajectoire à cause d'une alerte à la
bombe
les rebords de mise car affirmé quant à
lui que l' alerte à la bombe été
révélées erronées
après une fouille du boeing n'est le
président alexandre loukachenko a quant
à lui ordonné personnellement
d'intercepter l'avion après cette alerte
a déclaré son service de presse merci
verhaeghe hoffman en direct de moscou
et pour en parler nous retrouvons tout
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales rebond soir faisant ce
maison merci d'être avec nous pour
évoquer également cette actualité
la journée parce qu'on va tâcher d'y
voir plus clair dans cette affaire qui
semble invraisemblable
pourquoi la biélorussie at elle pris
cette décision selon vous de détourner
un avion et pourquoi hier ah ben je
crois que le président alexandre
loukachenko l'a fait sciemment en
connaissance de cause alors la première
la première chose c'est que en faisant
atterrir cet avion et en arts et en se
décidant qu'ils avaient trouvé un asile
politique en lituanie eh bien il
signifie à tous ses opposants à tous les
opposants à son régime
où qu'ils soient y en a beaucoup en
pologne lituanie en effet qui ne sont à
l'abri de rien que tout peut leur
arriver et qu'il ne sont pas en sécurité
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point je crois que le président
alexandre loukachenko dans le fonds
prend le set 7 cette occasion il a fait
atterrir cet avion de force sachant
pertinemment que ceci provoquerait des
protestations énergiques de tous les
pays occidentaux est probablement la
décision de sanctions de la part de la
plupart des pays occidentaux ce qui de
son point de vue élargirait le fossé
entre les pays occidentaux et l'alliance
entre la russie la biélorussie alliance
à laquelle il attache la plus grande
importance parce que c'est sa seule
bouée de sauvetage au bout du compte et
il voit mal la russie le désavouer et
puis
effectivement cette affaire de messages
du hamas disant qu'il y avait une bombe
et bah là encore il faut faire
authentifier ce message s'il ya vraiment
un message du havre du hamas
il doit pouvoir être authentifié par les
spécialistes sa loi ça devrait être
possible mais personne n'y croit
véritablement et c'est bien ça le
problème
et je crois que monsieur loukachenko
s'en moque un petit peu parce que si la
cie cet événement s'est produit hier
c'est parce qu'aussi aujourd'hui ce soir
c'est la réunion du conseil européen et
que monsieur le cachet coup s'est ainsi
invitée à la table du conseil européen
on devait discuter de sujets très
sérieux on devait discuter de la sortie
de la pandémie de la stratégie de
vaccination dans l'union européenne du
passeport vaccinale pour rétablir la
liberté de circulation à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
on devait aussi parler d'ailleurs des
rapports futurs avec la russie des
rapports avec le royaume uni du break
site est évidemment tout va se
concentrer en tout cas dans un premier
temps sur cette affaire est intervenue
hier soir il paraît tout à fait encore
beau laisse alors monsieur k c'est qu'on
sait aussi pertinemment que les états
membres sont divisés et que ça sera sans
doute difficile d'aboutir à l'unanimité
pour décider de nouvelles sanctions
il ya déjà des sanctions suite à
l'élection présidentielle contestée du
mois d'août dernier 88 personnalités
biélorusses sont sanctionnées c'est à
dire que elles n'ont pas accès à des
visas pour des pays de l'union
européenne elles ne peuvent pas d'avoir
d'avoirs financiers dans ces pays ça
n'est pas très grave puisque aucun de
ses 88 personnage n'avait l'intention de
passer ses vacances en europe
et s'il y avait des comptes dans les
banques de l'union européenne
ces comptes sont partis depuis très
longtemps dans les directions asiatiques
mais effectivement il est question
aujourd'hui de mettre davantage de
sanctions
claude le sommet de l'union européenne à
député débuté tout à l'heure son ordre
du jour quelque peu été évidemment
chamboulé par cette affaire l'europe qui
semble quand même clairement
prendre des choses très au sérieux oui
parce que en effet les expressions très
très très très dur ont été utilisés
piraterie étatique terrorisme étatique
est effectivement la plupart des
institutions sont se sont émus de cette
possibilité pour un état de faire
atterrir de force à un avion pour au
bout du compte récupérer un de ses
nationaux qui avait reçu l'asile
diplomatique dans un autre pays palazy
diplomatique la des politiques dans un
autre pays donc c'est difficilement
acceptable pour les états de l'union
européenne et il va y avoir une
discussion sur la conduite à tenir
monsieur le cas de chèques ou est
persuadé qu'il n'y a pas d'unanimité
pour appliquer des sanctions
peut-être se trompe-t-il peut-être se
trompe-t-il on verra ça d'ici demain
mais il ya différentes catégories de
sanctions en effet on peut allonger la
liste des 90 personnes déjà sanctionné
même si c'est un peu symbolique comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure on peut aussi
comme l'a proposé la belgique interdire
à la la société d'aviation nationale de
d'atterrir sur les aéroports de l'union
européenne on peut aussi aller un peu
plus loin en évidemment en restreignant
la circulation à travers entre les
frontières de la biélorussie et l'union
européenne
cela dit c'est un jeu un peu dangereux
parce que il n'est pas d'intérêt de
l'union européenne de restreint des
mouvements de population entre la
biélorussie et l'europe
les contacts entre les populations
civiles sont souhaitables
c'est dans l'intérêt de la grande europe
et puis il ya aussi un problème
particulier avec le territoire russe qui
se trouve être le territoire de
kaliningrad et qui est en fait est
enclavée à l'intérieur de deux 2 pays
européens que sont la lituanie et
la pologne et à l'époque où la lituanie
et la pologne sont rentrés dans l'union
européenne on a négocié avec la russie
l'union européenne a négocié avec la
russie de façon à assurer la liberté de
circulation des russe de kaliningrad et
des russes du reste de la russie et la
liberté aussi de circulation des
marchandises et de toutes sortes
d'équipements
alors il ne faudrait pas qu'en voulant
contrôler la frontière de biélorussie on
leur met encore en cause cet accord est
également tout à fait essentiel à
l'intégrité de la russie donc c'est un
sujet très délicat très sensible sur
lequel le conseil européen prendra sans
doute une décision de principe
probablement plus symbolique que réelle
et puis enfin comme ça été dit tout à
l'heure
l'organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale dont le siège est à
montréal dans tous les pays font partie
est chargé d'assurer la liberté de tous
les vols de tous les vols civils et qui
par conséquent doit mener une enquête
alors on vient d'annoncer que l'oaci
convoque une réunion pour jeudi
pourquoi je dis et pourquoi pas demain
il est essentiel de faire la lumière sur
les éléments factuels que s'est-il
produit réellement sous quels sous
quelles indications at on décidé de cet
atterrissage forcé un avion civil de sa
d'un avion de ryanair qui faisait la
liaison entre atel et vilnius deux
villes de pays qui appartiennent à
l'union européenne
et pourquoi at on arrêté ce passager qui
certes est un dissident en biélorussie
mais qui est aussi un réfugié politique
en lituanie par conséquent je crois que
loin ci doit absolument faire très
rapidement la lumière et il ya des
règles à appliquer il ya une convention
de chicago qui régit la liberté des vols
civils et qui probablement a été violée
dans ce cas particulier on merci
beaucoup claude blanche maison
l'actualité en france à présent plaintes
croisées d'audrey pulvar et de gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
avait annoncé sa plainte dans un tweet
hier soir dénonçant une interview dans
laquelle la candidate socialiste en ile
de france jugé assez glissante la
manifestation policière devant
l'assemblée nationale mercredi dernier
cette dernière a porté plainte à son
tour les là ça passe d'armes politique
entre gérald darmanin et audrey pulvar
le ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé
avoir déposé une plainte contre la
candidate investie par le ps en
ile-de-france pour les régionales
en cause des propos tenus par l'ex
journaliste à propos de la dernière
manifestation des policiers jugés
diffamatoires par gérald darmanin
l'image de cette manifestation était je
cite assez glaçante
selon audrey pulvar une manifestation de
policiers en colère soutenu par
l'extrême droite à laquelle participe un
ministre de l'intérieur qui marche sur
l'assemblée nationale pour faire
pression sur les députés en train
d'examiner un texte de loi concernant la
justice
c'est une image qui pour moi était assez
glaçante c'est au nom du ministère de
l'intérieur que l'ex maire de tourcoing
porter plainte
une plainte qui vise également une vidéo
de juin 2020 ou audrey pulvar brocardait
le racisme de la police des propos qui
pourraient toutefois être frappé par la
prescription
les propos de madame pulvar dépasse le
simple cadre d'une campagne électorale
et viennent profondément diffamé la
police de la république je porte plainte
au nom du ministère de l'intérieur et la
réponse de la candidat socialiste ne
s'est pas fait attendre
l'équipe de campagne ile-de-france en
commun a publié ce lundi après midi un
communiqué audrey pulvar porte plainte à
son tour contre gérald darmanin
nous récusons une quelconque diffamation
d'audrey pulvar à l'égard de la police
nationale et nous avons pris la décision
de porter plainte contre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin pour
diffamation et dénonciation calomnieuse
le ministre de l'intérieur avait suscité
la controverse dans l'opposition en
participant à cette manifestation
policière qui avait réuni trente cinq
mille personnes selon les
mais on en parle tout de suite avec
alexis poulain éditorialise bonsoir
alexis merci d'être avec nous faudrait
pulvar et gérald darmanin qui portent
plainte l'un contre l'autre en pleine
campagne pour les élections régionales
régionales une simple coïncidence bien
sûr oui sans doute non c'est clairement
malheureux ça montre finalement
l'inanité du débat politique où on en
vient à utiliser la justice comme un
faire-valoir pour faire monter ou
descendre un candidat sur des bases
totalement fallacieuse est ce le rôle
d'un ministre de l'intérieur de
manifester avec des policiers non ce
n'était déjà pas le cas est ce le rôle
ensuite d'un ministre de l'intérieur de
porter plainte pour les propos d'une
responsable politique en campagne non
plus c'est totalement déplacées et
personne dans ce gouvernement pour
recadrer gérald darmanin et lui dire
qu'il devrait s'occuper de l'insécurité
s'occupait également des forces de
police et de leurs revendications
on est là dans une campagne politicienne
où la justice est totalement
instrumentalisée et audrey pulvar l'a
compris d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle utilise exactement l'effet
boomerang l'effet streisand en disant eh
bien puisque gérald darmanin m'attaque
c'est à mon tour de contre-attaquer en
l'attaquant à son tour pour diffamation
ça n'ira nulle part ce sont des plaintes
totalement ubuesque c'est du temps perdu
c'est surtout assez grave pour le climat
politique parce que ça montre que la
liberté de parole est de plus en plus
encadré plus en plus contraintes y
compris pour des responsables politiques
qui ont quand même assez une assez
grande latitude pour prendre la parole
notamment en temps de campagne
électorale donc c'est un précédent qui
ne doit pas être pris à la légère parce
que ça voudrait dire que demain
n'importe quel candidat pourrait être
accusée par un ministre de diffamation
ou autres et être souffrir de procédure
bayon le fameux lot faire à la façon
dont la justice peut être
instrumentalisée par le pouvoir en place
pour empêcher les opposants de montella
en l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas ça
fait beaucoup de publicité pour audrey
pulvar elle doit dire merci gérald
darmanin
ça permet dans la dernière ligne droite
de la campagne des régionales de la
positionner clairement comme une
candidate de gauche face à un ministre
de droite ministre d'emmanuel mâcon qui
mélange les genres sans jamais comme je
le disais être recadré par l'exécutif
on comprend l'intérêt d'audrey pulvar
quel est le but poursuivi en revanche
par le ministre
de l'intérieur a signé une candidate au
silence comme le déclare l'avocat
d'audrey pulvar non parce qu'elle est
elle bien sûr qu'elle n'est pas assigné
au silence est elle réelle répliqué au
contraire c'est pour elle un porte voix
formidable non je crois que la manoeuvre
pour gérald darmanin ces deux prolongé
la séquence de la manifestation des
syndicats policiers devant l'assemblée
nationale où ça s'est très mal passé
pour lui il pensait reconnecter avec la
base en étant parmi les manifestants il
s'est fait lui ça a été un fiasco
donc là il essaye de raccrocher les
wagons avec les syndicats policiers qui
avaient demandé à ce que ses propos
soient soient sanctionnés par le
ministre don qu'il obéit aux syndicats
il est dans une course finalement pour
montrer combien il va tout faire pour
satisfaire les demandes des syndicats
est resté en place et être un ministre
aimait de ses troupes
même si c'est loin d'être le cas donc
pour lui la manoeuvre est clairement
politique gérald darmanin pense déjà au
coude après qu'est ce qu'il fera après
beauvau il faut qu'il sorte par le haut
avec des bons chiffres avec aussi un
bilan positif et des policiers qui
trouveront qu'il a été un bon ministre
de l'intérieur parce que fait gérald
darmanin
eh bien ils copient il marche dans les
pas de son maître de son mentor nicolas
sarkozy qui a été à ministre de
l'intérieur et mais à l'époque papa par
les policiers même si il a il avait fait
beaucoup de mesures qui maintenant sont
critiqués par la police donc on est là
vraiment dans une manoeuvre politicienne
à somme nulle parce que je ne crois pas
que gérald darmanin va en retirer
immédiatement les bénéfices en
l'occurrence ils se ridiculisent plutôt
avec 7 contre plainte d'une candidate
aux régionales alors que lui est
ministre et qu'il a bien d'autres choses
à faire dans ses fonctions régaliennes
trailer qui a le plus à perdre dans
cette passe d'armes selon vous gérald
darmanin comme vous semblez l'expliquer
oui clairement pour moi c'est lui qui
perd un peu de sa stature régaliennes
qui perd aussi de sa fonction
ministérielle à rentrer dans une
politique politicienne pour des
régionales on n'est même pas sûr un
enjeu national donc on se demande qu'est
ce qu'il va faire dans cette galère
d'une certaine façon à part comme je
viens de le dire essayer de satisfaire
les syndicats policiers les rassurer et
gagner du temps à la tête du ministère
de l'intérieur mais pour lui
c'est pas une manoeuvre qui va forcément
lui être bénéfique dans l'immédiat
contrairement à dry pulvar qui elle va
pouvoir surfer sur cette étiquette de
candidates montré du doigt ou attaqués
par le ministre de l'intérieur sur
d'ailleurs des fallacieux motif je ne
pense pas que la justice ira très loin
dans cette affaire c'est vraiment de la
posture et ça montre qu'on est en train
de passer de la politique spectacle à un
triste spectacle de la politique est une
fois de plus le ps qui soutient tout de
même sa candidate coûte que coûte un oui
c'est normal on ne va pas changer de
candidate les listes ont été déposées
donc audrey pulvar est la candidate
investie par le ps il va falloir la
soutenir coûte que coûte même si on sent
bien les contorsions et parfois les
gênes 1 du côté de la maire de paris
anne hidalgo qui a pris ses distances
qui est revenu audrey pulvar elle est
assez nouvelle dans ce jeu politique
elle a fait quelques erreurs elle
continue d'étonner dans le paysage
politique avec des déclarations qui
parfois peuvent sembler choquant pour
ses camarades du parti socialiste
mais le choix a été fait elle est la
candidate en ile de france elle va donc
aller jusqu'au bout et le ps va devoir
la soutenir
et en l'occurrence c'est plutôt
bénéfique d'avoir cette plainte du
ministre comme je le disais en termes
d'audimat en termes d'audience de
visibilité ça permet de la mettre sur le
devant sans même parler du programme que
défend le parti socialiste pour la
région ile de france
merci alexis poulin et en france
toujours un seul numéro d'urgence
pourrait bientôt remplacer les nombreux
que l'on connaît déjà comme le 15 le 18
ou le 17 pour la police un projet de loi
qui sera débattue à l'assemblée
nationale dès mercredi 27 alors que déjà
les uns et les autres le font savoir
baisse en chimie
on le croyait disparu et voilà que le
numéro unique d'appel d'urgence fait son
grand retour dans les débats un projet
de loi porté par le parlementaire lrm
fabien matras le 12 mai dernier les
députés ont déjà voté en commission
l'expérimentation d'un numéro unique
d'appel d'urgence 112 qui devrait
remplacer les treize numéros d'urgence
dont les fameux 10 cette vision
et 15 une expérimentation de trois ans
qui est loin de faire l'unanimité le
projet de loi doit être débattu dès
mercredi prochain au palais bourbon mais
déjà politiques et professionnels sont
montés au créneau samu urgences ou
encore personnels hospitaliers sont plus
de 250 avoir signé une tribune publiée
dans le journal du dimanche
objectif alerter les pouvoirs publics
sur la dangerosité et l'inefficacité
d'un tel regroupement de services
destinés à protéger et à servir la
population sur le fait que consacrer le
112 comme numéro d'appel d'urgence
unique pour tous les services
reviendrait à faire le choix d'une
réponse aux appels d'urgence à la fois
moins efficace voire dangereuse et plus
coûteuses pour le contribuable
seul un médecin est capable de définir
avec l'aplomb la gravité de la situation
médicale
il explique en d'autres termes que les
réformes et les politiques ne peuvent
pas toujours se substituer à l'être
humain selon françois braun président du
syndicat samu urgences de france
un intermédiaire entre le samu et le
patient pourrait avoir de lourdes
conséquences notamment en perturbant
l'analyse de l'urgence et du besoin des
patients
dégradé le principe de régulation c'est
déstabiliser toute l'organisation des
soins si ce n'est pas un professionnel
qui décroche il va réagir par excès sans
cette régulation un appel égale un envoi
d'ambulances un transport vers l'hôpital
si cette réticence semble avoir une idée
services de santé les sapeurs pompiers
eux al'inverse des signataires sont
plutôt favorables à ce projet de loi le
citoyen qui appelle les secours souvent
doit se prêter à un jeu de piste pour
arriver au bon endroit pour les soldats
du feu le numéro unique qui a déjà fait
ses preuves à l'étranger pourrait être
un gain de temps précieux surtout dans
les cas d'urgence vitale
le numéro unique a largement fait ses
preuves à l'étranger pays bas belgique
suède finlande etats unis canada un
premier niveau de réponse localise
l'appel et définit la nature de
l'urgence puis transfert vers le service
métier compétents à caen en france
d'un côté un projet défendu par le
ministère de l'intérieur et certains
fidèles parlementaire de l'autre la
réalité du quotidien plusieurs millions
d'appels d'urgence qui pourrait souffrir
d'une nouvelle réforme privilégiant une
fois de plus la sous traitance et la
segmentation des
service et pour en parler nous sommes
avec pierre frédéric billets mer et
l'air de dreux président du conseil de
surveillance du centre hospitalier de
dreux bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
alors vous faites partie des signataires
de cette tribune qu est ce que vous
reprochez à ce projet bonsoir oui alors
différents reproche le premier temps que
nous sommes dans un contexte un peu
particulier en ce moment c'est vrai que
depuis 18 mois la copie de frappe le
monde hospitalier
et si oui on a l'impression quand même
qu'on remet en cause la loi busin qui a
été votée à deux ans sur les plateformes
de téléphones et une centrale d'appels
pour toutes les questions de santé et de
secours c'est bien différencier et que
on vient encore percuté le monde
hospitalier avec une réforme qui n'a pas
été concerté avec le monde hospitalier
et qui vient d'être mis en place comme
un cheveu sur la soupe alors que le
contexte est ultra sensible dans tous
les hôpitaux de france et donc voilà il
faut être raisonnable il faut prendre le
temps des choses la loi le projet de loi
matras on peut en discuter il ya des
choses qui sont intéressantes mais en
tout cas sur la plateforme unique et le
numéro unique
je pense et avec mes collègues nous
pensons que c'est une bêtise qui ne
rendra pas sa liste meilleur à nos
concitoyens
pourtant on entend quand même des
arguments de bon sens souvent les
pompiers d'ailleurs qui sont plutôt pour
cette initiative explique ce moment
c'est que je piste pour les administrés
qui se perdent un pied peu dans tous les
numéros se serait pas une manière
justement de centraliser et qui est être
aiguillés correctement après alors tout
à fait si vous voulez l'idée de la loi
busin était intéressant c'est de dire
faisons deux métiers différents
donc vous avez les services de secours
qu'on appelle les sapeurs pompiers
notamment et les services de santé fait
qu'on appelle le samu mais qui peut
regrouper d'autres choses dont on peut
avoir le 115 pour les personnes sans
domicile fixe
françaises de 110,9 qui peut vous paie
toutes les questions de santé
c'est assez intéressant et les services
de secours simplement c'est que quelques
chiffres pour comprendre la situation
aujourd'hui nous avons 29 millions
d'appels par an au service des familles
22 millions pour les sapeurs pompiers
sauf et 29 millions d'appels que le samu
reçoit partout en france la moitié des
appels sont traités directement au
téléphone par simple conseil avec des
agents régulateur avec des médecins
coordinateurs pour que les gens aient un
bon conseil et soient bien dirigées les
sapeurs pompiers font inviter de secours
et donc ont le réflexe plus souvent de
faire déplacer les véhicules et du
personnel sur place pour prendre en
charge les personnes parfois c'est utile
et parfois c'est pas utile
donc c'est à dire que si on devait avoir
un numéro de téléphone unique
malheureusement on viendrait engorgé
parfois sans raison les services
d'urgence qui font extrêmement tendues
depuis des années est d'autant plus
depuis un an et demi on a vu également
dans le sujet que beaucoup de pays il
utilise notamment par exemple la
belgique tout simplement il ya le canada
les pays bas et que ça se passe plutôt
bien ça veut dire quoi que nos systèmes
sont pas vraiment comparables alors déjà
il faut comprendre que les services de
secours fait de me refaire l'intérieur
les services de santé fait les
ministères de l'affronter alors sortons
un peu de ce fantasme du numéro du 112
il utilisait par quelques pays en europe
c'est frêche mais c'est pas la majorité
et puis si vous voulez faut bien
comprendre que une seule plate forme de
téléphone c'est aussi prendre un risque
en cas de panne d' attaques de virus d'
attaques de hackers que cette plate
forme pendant plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs jours ne puissent plus
fonctionner savez dans l'armée on dit un
truc assez simple on dit de ses 1 et 1 0
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
sécuriser les appels avec deux
plateformes bien distinctes qui le cas
échéant quand il ya un problème puisse
prendre le relais du premier kit en
panne et ça c'est une vraie sécurité
pour nos concitoyens pour les services
de secours les services de santé
est-ce qu'ils aient enfin un avantage
économique à n'avoir qu'un seul
numéro dans un pays malheureusement qui
a bien besoin manifestement de
d'économie semble-t-il
alors alors vous savez les grandes
réformes imaginez à paris quand les
voies sion terrain c'est souvent
catastrophiques
vous verrez que si malheureusement cette
récente va se mettre en place dans
quelques mois on créera des postes pour
la coordination la coopération et au
final ça coûtera plus cher
vous savez il ya il ya une mouvance
comme ça en ce moment on supprime le
corps préfectoral pour des raisons qu'on
ne comprend pas bien les réformes de
grandes institutions qu'on regroupés
après sa part fait que ça fonctionne
plus on les sépare
c'est des mouvements sans cesse de
d'état moi je suis très prudent moi je
fais confiance aux acteurs locaux
je fais confiance aux hospitaliers qui
ont prouvé durant
kovy des encours du site sienne que sont
des gens sérieux il faut la faire
confiance savez les sapeurs pompiers ils
ont besoin d'une chose ils ont besoin
d'une reconnaissance donc sans
financière et de moyens et des
hospitaliers c'est pareil de la
reconnaissance mais c'est dé travailler
les faits les tranquilles et surtout
monsieur monsieur le ministre
écoutez vos hospitality connaissent très
bien terrain etc ont besoin d'écouté et
d'appui n'en fait qu'on prenne forme
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec mon cher
frédéric biais là pour évoquer ce sujet
mer et l'air de dreux ac avec nous dans
quelques instants nous partirons à
bruxelles où se tient actuellement un
sommet européen les 27 dénonce la
violation des accords signés lors du
divorce et puis direction les états unis
un an après la mort de giorgio foid ce
mardi joe biden recevra sa famille alors
qu'une réforme de la police est en cours
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes
j'ai vraiment plongé dans une atmosphère
où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé gagarine
était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station milliards ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi au
site
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu'il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry allons
faire connaissance vous avez choisi le
jour à bagdad alors je suis arrivé en
2005 pour étudier dernière fois celle en
profiter en 2011 le nom demande pas un
petit peu non ah oui et c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la plonge
et autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter
bon courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
le terme banlieue voir le terme 6 pts et
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et en donne
séparation que la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police qui serait son travail
c'est plus compliqué que ça on est
français on est fiers de vivre dans ces
quartiers même si à des difficultés et
la moindre des choses c'est d'inscrire
aussi notre empreinte canton quand on
participe à la vie de la société et
malheureusement n'y a pas cette
reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus merci nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france les vingt-sept
réunis depuis tout à l'heure à bruxelles
si l'ordre du jour a quelque peu été
chamboulée depuis l'interception hier
par la biélorussie d'un avion de ligne
les relations plutôt tendues entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni
devraient être abordés notamment la
question de la pêche à laquelle tient
particulièrement paris pour en parler
nous sommes avec paul thompson
vice-président du parti conservateur
britannique en france
bonsoir paul thompson alors si
l'actualité ne rattrape pas à le sommer
que peut-on attendre de ce conseil par
rapport spécifique ment aux relations
entre lui et le royaume uni depuis la
signature du bric site il ya maintenant
cinq mois je suppose qu'il y aura
quelque chose ressemblant à une
déclaration de bonnes intentions même
déclaration de d'inquiétude qui aurait
une fonction politique à savoir pour
pour réagir aux hommes à blaye
problématique tu auras de la pêche et et
de deux rangs du non ce sont les deux
sujets les plus et plus brûlants jeu le
jeu quoi je ne m'attendais pas vraiment
à une décision concrète ou changer les
modalités se rattachant cessé de se
gérer la pêche et de protocoles de
l'élan d'une oie parce que l'une de la
fonction du sommet c'est plutôt des
fixes et des grandes lignes politiques
alors sur la question de la pêche paul
thompson après des accrochages on s'en
souvient entre pêcheurs français et les
autorités de new jersey rien n'a semblé
champ que je change rien ne la sent
d'échangés semble-t-il l'europe at elle
a tapé du poing sur la table
je ne m'étonnerais pas quelqu'un le
fasse mais j'ai cru comprendre qu'il ya
quand même un groupe de travail 1
bilatérale qui a été constituée pour
s'attaquer
et à des questions techniques il faut se
il faudra bien en tête que ces accords
sont quelque chose de nouveau et se
trouve que je sais juste que juriste
quand il ya de nouvelles lois nouveau
règlement dans n'importe quel domaine
il a un prix assez couramment qu'il y à
une autre période de rodage ou au
découvre dans la pratique des
difficultés auxquelles on n'a pas bien
réfléchir en préparant le le texte et
honnêtement je pense que en ce qui
concerne la pratique de cash
on est plutôt dans ce ce cas de figure
le problème c'est qu'il ya aussi une
dimension émotionnelle et est purement
politique
à chaque parti ne veut pas perdre la
face et il y a une certaine nervosité
qui plane au dessus des nouvelles
relations générales entre le royaume uni
et l union européenne donc à chaque
partie veut défendre son territoire sans
être totalement déraisonnable non plus
donc chacun se cherche un peu et sur le
qui vive mais je pense que la raison
finira par prévaloir
quant au protocole le nord-irlandais en
cdd deuxième sujet comme vous nous
disiez la provence qui reste pour partie
dans le marché européen intérieur cela
complique les choses au niveau
commercial il faudra modifier l'accord
sous peine peut-être de raviver des
tensions
personnellement je vous tends à penser
que oui effectivement je sais que
certaines personnes se disent choqués
par une telle idée est bien sûr il est
vrai que quand on signe un accord censé
s'y tenir
appliquer les dispositions et ainsi de
suite
le principe d'application générale et sa
soeur cliquer ici
comme comme ailleurs seulement le
pourquoi il faut quand même réfléchir où
elle raison d'être de ce protocole la
sueur des vents du nord
la raison d'être elle concerne des
questions de sécurité et de préservation
de la deûle atteint h sur l'île
d'irlande il allait comme de communes et
communautés catholique et protestante et
on a voulu éviter
new frontier dure entre la république
tant dans les rangs du nord parce que
par le passé quand il y avait des postes
douaniers am cela simulait des des
partisans violon des des deux côtés à se
livrer à des opérations de classe 10 kg
ce qui n'est pas de nature à améliorer
la date au stade général était donc pour
éviter ce genre de problème on a dit non
il faut mettre le lait contient au
milieu de la mer du nord
simplement ce qu'on constate c'est que
cette approche elle même génère des des
difficultés voire des troubles en
irlande du nord
et ça c'est une réalité qui n'a pas et
qui étiez survenu sur le 13 et elle n'a
pas été concocté dans la cuisine de
nombreux thèmes dernier suit nous se
sont ils à de véritables inquiétudes à
et entre les communautés catholiques
protestants en irlande du nord il y a
une âme atmosphère assez mauvaise
aujourd'hui elle tant qu'on n'a pas vue
depuis longtemps donc les autorités
britanniques disent il faut traiter
cette situation ne pas simplement faire
comme si elles n'existaient pas ce
serait irresponsable est d'ailleurs
encore par rapport à la
au but de secours local qui était de
permettre que le rapport est sereine
sert un an les catholiques et les
protestants on voit que ce nouveau
régime pieds posés par complication et
sur petit et copie donc il faudrait à
mon avis si attaqué à l'essai de trouver
des améliorations à tout en respectant
l'esprit elle il hésite et de bassins un
petit creux nullement une carte fast pas
de l'union européenne de dire là il ya
des améliorations à à faire il faut
parler avec nos amis britanniques à 10
ans avec dublin pour améliorer le régime
je pense que ça veut ni plus ni moins
que cela il faut avoir un esprit
merci paul comme ça non je rappelle que
vous êtes un vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
merci votre médecin aux états unis à
présent le 25 mai demi de vin d'orge
fred moore et sous le genou du policier
derek chauvine après dix minutes
d'agonie un nom après et malgré de
nombreux soutiens à travers le monde
l'appelait n'est toujours pas refermée
julien duroux à minneapolis
on oublie pas près de 1500 personnes ont
battu le pavé ce dimanche dans la ville
du minnesota auprès des proches de
georges floyd
l'objectif de cette marche honorer sa
mémoire tout en faisant passer un
message bien clair celui du changement
[Applaudissements]
mais quand amélie est georges floyd ne
restera pas dans l'histoire en tant que
martyr
il restera comme celui qui a fait
changer des choses quand vous êtes tombé
sur son cou vous avez brisé celui de
l'inconduite de la police dans ce pays
nous resterons dans la rue jusqu'à ce
que passe la loi contre les abus
policiers
le rassemblement a débuté par des
discours devant le bâtiment ou derek
chauvine a été reconnu coupable de
meurtre le 20 avril dernier l'ancien
policier connaîtra sa peine le 25 juin
prochain
d'ici là la famille de georges klein
dont ont continué de faire porter sa
voix
cet agent ignorer ce qui allait se
passer en dernier
je vais continuer de maintenir debout
oui je serai la voix de georges je vais
rester debout je serai le changement
pour lui je vais rester debout et je
vais continuer d'incarner son héritage
depuis la mort de georges floyd diverses
entreprises et administrations ont
promis des résolutions allant dans le
sens de l'égalité raciale à austin au
texas
on essaie depuis un an de réformer le
budget alloué à la police une partie de
ce budget doit notamment être réinvestis
dans un certain nombre de programmes
sociaux de santé et de prévention de la
violence
une baisse des dépenses dans le but
d'orchestrer le début du changement
voulu par les proches de georges floyd
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis new york avec shadwick mot aux
journalistes politiques c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir shadwick moore merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un an donc
après la mort de georges auteuil est ce
qu'on peut dire que cette affaire a
suscité un véritable sursaut antiraciste
ya eu un véritable avant et après ça
fait la même chose il ya plusieurs
années lorsque le parti blackglama
twitter est apparu libre cette hystérie
anti racistes avant les élections donc
cela continue encore mais ce qui est
arrivé c'est différent on passe de la
violence a contrôlé par la police
[Musique]
mais une fois c'est qu'on demande
en fait la conséquence c'est qu'on veut
des finances et la police illuminé la
police dans les états unis et le
résultat c'est qu'ils aient une hausse
très forte des crimes violents dans
toute l'étendue de notre actu il ya une
baisse importante de la qualité de vue
dans une ville cela rend la vie pire
pour tout le monde
ce que ces militants ne comprennent pas
c'est qu'ils ne regardent pas les
statistiques des crimes ils ne savent
pas ce que c'est que la police ait une
sco n'est ce pas les formations
policières
juste des théories du complot esprits et
les dirigeants de ces villes sont
terrifiés de la cje en feu et à leur
demande
prendre en compte ce qui permet à une
ville d'être sécurisée pour tout le
monde
est-ce que par ailleurs ça a tout de
même provoqué un changement au sein de
la police il ya du changement dans la
police mais un changement négatif
beaucoup d'officiers de police en
démissionner
son parti à la retraite anticipée à lyon
cela est arrivé à minneapolis également
à new york
j'ai parlé à des officiers de police à
new york et qui m'ont dit vous oubliez
tout ce qu'il savait sur la police et la
police des vitres cassées c'est à dire
il s'agissait de s'occuper de problèmes
de qualité de vie de problèmes de
sécurité générale on leur dit que il ne
faut plus faire la police comme ça
maintenant les policiers sont des cibles
des policiers doivent être très prudents
lorsqu'ils utilisent lorsqu'ils font
usage de la force et du coup la police
de vienne devient moins rétive
il ya moins d'engagement la police est
plus haute en mesure de faire son
travail a car elle a peur d'être la
cible de foule elle a peur de se faire
mettre à la porte
elle a peur d'être filmé dans des actes
ne sont peut-être pas illégaux mais qui
ont l'air mauvais et donc effectivement
le travail de la police a changé
démocrates promettent des finances et la
police se rend compte en suisse et vous
visitez cela est déjà arrivé dans cet
état la police l'a la villa premier est
de diminuer le budget de la police et
font en fait le contraire car ils se
rendent compte que la criminalité se
renforce dans leur circonscription et
qu' il n'y a que la police pour gérer le
problème
alors la famille floyd est en tout cas
elle est devenue en un an un ambassadeur
très efficace en de cette lutte contre
les violences policières
aux etats unis la famille qui va être
reçue demain d'ailleurs par joe biden
qu'est ce que ça dit
parle pas de la fois où il l'a pointé
une arme mais contre une femme enceinte
et a été arrêté pour cela il a été
vraiment sanctifié sa famille a reçu
beaucoup d'argent de la ville de
minneapolis
la maison blanche veut être montrée
comme étant supporter yves de cette
famille mais ce qui se passe vraiment ce
qui change c'est que la situation
s'améliore pour personne un sondage
récent sur plusieurs milliers de
d'américains a découvert que 80% des
hommes noirs américains la mienne le
temps du patient policière dans le
voisinage donc cela l'offre que c'est
démocrate radicaux ne sont pas
véritablement la fois de la communauté
qu'ils prétendent représenter à chicago
par exemple le nombre de crimes commis
par des noirs sur des noirs est très
élevé c'est la première cause de décès
accidentel de jeunes noirs aux états
unis et pas la position
aucune idée de ce à quoi ressemble le
travail de la police
les morts par policiers sont en fait
très réduit très très petit nombre des
interactions de la police avec mais un
citoyen doit par conséquent sa vie a
demandé c'est tout cela c'est une
question de politique cela n'a rien à
voir avec les ignore ou la protection
des personnes noires pour protéger les
noirs il faudrait plus de policiers
dans les quartiers la violence des zones
noires sur les noirs et galopante
l'ignorent il ne vais pas en parler
il valait produire une sorte de
révolution marxiste du système et c'est
terrible et personne dans la presse ne
sous l'armure l'hypocrisie personne nous
dira que la grande majorité des
policiers des personnes qui a de bonnes
intentions personne ne veut devenir
policier pour briser des crânes et donc
ces gens ne représentent pas l'immense
majorité des citoyens de nos communautés
et ne représente pas non plus l'immense
majorité était noir merci beaucoup chez
quick mort genlis politique d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité à 22h
[Musique]
tous
le terme banlieue voire le top 6 tc
forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que les
médias ont un regard on va dire assez
particulier des banlieues et qui dérange
aujourd'hui et en donne cette impression
de la banlieue ça se résoudrait cas des
jeunes violents contre une police qui
serait son travail c'est plus compliqué
que ça on est français on est fiers de
vivre dans ces quartiers même si les
difficultés et la moindre des choses
c'est d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte
canton quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement il n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses
mais concrètement politiquement ils ne
le font pas
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable une gouvernance
responsable moderne plutôt que de se
repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est pris